oi rô mãe
a mãe da nato presa
e de toda saber mesa de todo explicando
um
o filme prostr uatt a louvar o feminino
em mim
e ao declarar o meu amor eu sou eu vou
retirando aos poucos esse véu você me
acorda muito mostra os passos que eu
devo seguir sem hesitar se que não posso
resistir ao seu chamado muito eu busco
post e quero sempre poder lhe servir meu
coração eu abro para o amor e me entrego
ao seu valor
a sua força me traz o incentivo dessa
busca que eu vou na esperança de poder
ter seu amor para minha collins para o
eu ia para frente que se vai no tempo é
eterno que parece demorar me desconstruo
para poder me enxergar
o e bater asas como agiu beija-flor ô
mãe do amor que eu vejo em ti
e o mãe do amor que espelha em mim com
uma é bom te escutar o muito
o homem do amor que eu vejo em ti
a mamãe do amor que espelhinho como é
bom te encontrar
[Aplausos]